John along with director Comey the FBI
were a pair of truly Bad actors who and
I write about this in the book who on
January 6 2017 when the president had
not yet been sworn in went to Trump
Tower I was invited to be there I was
still just a member of Congress I was
the nominee to be the CI director went
to Trump Town basically told Donald
Trump that he was a Russian asset or
that they believed so and I am now even
more convinced that they knew that
wasn't true that they knew it was based
on unreliable unverified for sure
information and the harm that they did
forget to me or to Donald Trump the harm
that they did to our country is just
among the most dangerous things I have
seen come out of the intelligence
community in my lifetime
start this way for for the real portion
of the interview uh you know right now
when people say CIA FBI when when people
are hearing all of what's going on with
the Twitter files and seeming government
intelligence agency collusion with big
Tech and all of these things there's a
real I think warranted skepticism about
these agencies so can you just talk to
us a little bit about what the agencies
are like is all of this stuff warranted
is some of our worries unwarranted et
cetera et cetera
now the concern of governmental power is
one of the reasons I ran for congress
right too much too much power in
Washington D.C unchecked uh is something
that America has always had a
responsibility to protect against and
you can see it uh I I can speak most
directly to uh of the intelligence
agencies the CIA I worked with the FBI
on some projects but I I was never
responsible for it in the same way that
I got a chance to peer inside CIA
uh I took over from a man named John
Brennan the previous director who had
politicized that agency deeply uh he'd I
write about this in never give an inch
he he worked on this thing that
incorporated the steel dossier that
became the Russia hoax in ways that were
antithetical to good analysis good
intelligence that is so important for
the United States of America
and I I had to go back and rebuild
pieces of that
but the good news was
and this is different from the state
department which is a big bureaucracy
which frankly we can talk about is
hugely problematic but different at the
CIA at the ca most of the folks are
people who want to do America's Mission
and so when I came in and president
Trump came in yes sir got it this is the
direction you're going we're going to go
bang our head against the wall we're
going to go break through it we're going
to deliver for the American people as
you have directed us to do these are
young men and women who you know they
just want to put a dagger in their mouth
and go out and collect intelligence for
us and the risk is that you have
political leadership and in the end
presidents own that you have political
leadership that undermines both
America's confidence in the institutions
which is the skepticism you're referring
to but as equally bad as that as as
troubling as the the the absence of
confidence in the institution is is
they're not effective they're not on
Mission when they're spending their time
training on diversity equity and
inclusion when the green agenda and the
lgbt2 lgbtq agenda come to to dominate
the focus inside these institutions
you're undermining incredibly powerful
American tools that have kept us all
safe for an awfully a long time so when
you took the gig was it like day one
that you realized how politics and and
the Obama Staffing and everything that
Brennan was doing did you realize it on
day one how how dirty the whole thing
had become and how tough is it to go in
and try to clean up some of that stuff
so I'd seen it even before that I served
on the house intelligence committee so I
had been watching the dni operation the
CIA operation all of the intelligence
folks for four or five years and so I
knew that Brandon look this this
director of the CIA who refused to say
that the agency spied on foreigners just
like right no that's that's what its
task is to go do really good collections
so presidents can have good data sets to
make informed decisions and so I I knew
that director Brennan had taken this
agency off Mission off its focus and so
literally it's the case Dave on day one
I went in Built My Team some of from the
outside most of it frankly from the
inside that were still great and still
are great people there we identified
leaders we identified people who were
Pipers who were willing to go crush it
on behalf of America and change the
focus of the agency to deliver for the
president
so how has that now changed since you're
gone and obviously we have a new
Administration and I suspect they
probably like a lot of those Brennan
appointments that were there
and ideas yeah yeah it's it's different
um I will say this the current director
director Burns is not John Brennan
uh and so I think that's I think that's
fantastic John along with director
comment the FBI were a pair of truly Bad
actors who and I write about this in the
book who on January 6 2017 when the
president had not yet been sworn in went
to Trump Tower I was invited to be there
I was still just a member of Congress I
was the nominee to be the CI director
went to Trump basically told Donald
Trump that he was a Russian asset or
that they believed so and I am now even
more convinced that they knew that
wasn't true that they knew it was based
on unreliable unverified for sure
information and the harm that they did
forget to me or to Donald Trump the harm
that they did to our country is just
among the most dangerous things I have
seen come out of the intelligence
community in my lifetime what do you
make of how nobody seems to ever pay a
price for these things so when you talk
about you know the Steele dossier coming
out of this or the 50 former
intelligence officials that basically
said the hunter Biden laptop was Russian
disinformation which we know obviously
it now was not I think one of the
frustrations for average people is they
they see this and they go well nobody
seems to ever get fired actually the
people who lie end up with gigs on CNN
or in the government
yeah one of my biggest challenges was
John Brennan was out there on MSNBC
talking about all this stuff while I was
trying to run the CIA it was uh it was
hugely problematic because you had some
fraction of the workforce though wanted
to follow him and more importantly you
had this are you guys not told
beforehand I don't know who would tell
you but I mean is it shouldn't there be
some sort of code like if you ran the
thing you can't be on MSNBC or Fox a
week after you leave to to tell the
students yeah yeah and by the way that
was common practice a pretty common
practice look I don't have any problem
if what you're going out there is to
talk about the greatness of the
institution that you led and the people
really the people right but when you're
out there telling stories to your point
about the the Russia hoax John Brennan
and the folks who signed that document
clearly knew that this was likely not
Russian disinformation and so they
caveat it to be clever but the truth is
I think they all knew but they had a
political agenda and that's that's the
danger
um
you know these institutions matter an
awful lot
um we haven't spent as much time talking
about the FBI but to your point about
accountability we know that McCabe lied
we know that the FBI concluded that
McCabe lied and you know he's out on CNN
telling stories uh pretending he was a
good actor inside that institution when
in fact he along with the cohort around
him undermined the most basic principles
of our Republic
who do you really put the blame at with
all of this like do you feel that that's
a Brennan to blame or was that purely
that he was doing basically what Obama
appointed him to do
you know Dave I always hold the senior
leaders accountable
and and that holds true for our
administration too the things we got
wrong were my responsibility of the
president's responsibilities isn't a
partisan shot so I owe President Obama
responsible in fact with respect to this
dossier and the intelligence report that
was written Obama had directed that
report be written and publicized uh in
the fall of what would have been two
thousand and uh 16. after the election
he directed that they write this report
and that they make a classified version
an unclassified version that was
released that that's unheard of to have
that happen and so this was directed
from the highest levels uh last thought
people matter and so uh every president
has to be incredibly focused from before
day one on bringing the right people in
that not only share their policy views
but their value set and I think you can
see one of the things I regret is that
director Comey wasn't replaced
immediately at the beginning of our
Administration he sat inside of our team
while he was trying to undermine
everything it was that we were doing if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell